[Music]
the ancient city of Constantinople stood
for centuries as a beacon of strength
and resilience a Bastion of power that
seemed unbreakable but when its walls
finally crumbled it spelled the end of
an Empire and the birth of a new era of
Conquest I'm rich Burnett for one dream
and in this episode of perspectives
three experts discussed the inner
workings of the city's defenses the
tactics that finally overcame them and
the profound impact that this epic
battle had on the World As We Know It We
Begin now as we explore the key factors
that made this city a jewel of the
ancient world
by the end of the 5th Century A.D the
Western Roman Empire centered on Rome
had fallen or at the very least had been
transformed into something that was no
longer truly fully Roman
on the other side of the Mediterranean
the Eastern Roman Empire with its
capital at Constantinople most certainly
did not fall and would continue to
flourish for another 1 000 years
although they viewed themselves as
simply the Romans later historians have
labeled this Empire the Byzantine Empire
after the original name of the old Greek
colony Byzantium located at the site
where Constantinople would later be
built
today the same city has undergone yet
one more name change and is now Istanbul
in Turkey
by Constantine in the 4th Century to be
the Eastern capital of the Empire
Constantinople sits exactly at the
border between Europe and Asia
overlooking the Bosphorus the narrow
strip of water that both links the
Mediterranean Sea to the Black Sea and
separates Europe from Asia
geographically Constantinople commands a
vital economic and strategic Crossroads
the main trade routes connecting east to
west and north to south converge at this
single point
Constantinople was not only a key
Transportation node but also a frontier
or border Zone
it was in the streets and bazaars of the
city that the ideas and cultures of east
and west met and intermingled
somewhat like a northern version of
Alexandria and Egypt Constantinople
possessed a mixture of civilizations
that gave it a uniquely Cosmopolitan and
worldly character and enriched the
intellectual life of the city
because the city was on a stretch of
High Ground surrounded on three sides By
the Waters of the Sea of marmara the
Bosphorus and the Golden Horn it was
highly defensible
Constantinople could only be approached
by land on its western side and its
inhabitants constructed some of the most
massive fortifications of antiquity
along this one vulnerable approach
the walls that protected this great city
were built and rebuilt by a succession
of Emperors but by the 6th Century
comprised an impressive set of
fortifications
the walls were 36 feet high 17 feet
thick and had 96 great Towers spaced
along them a massive ditch excavated in
front of the walls added yet another
formidable obstacle
there were actually two sets of walls
one nested within the other with the
outer ones lower than the inner ones so
that even if the outermost wall was
captured the Defenders could simply
Retreat behind the higher inner wall and
then fire down on the exposed attackers
constantinople's location also made it a
beautiful city
even today when you approach it by C is
I've done a number of times you're
greeted with a spectacular Vista of
spiers and buildings rising up above the
shimmering water
the Strategic and aesthetic aspects of
its location were well appreciated in
Antiquity as well
in describing the city the 6th Century
historian procopius wrote
the sea is set most beautifully all
about it forming curving bays and thus
it makes the city exceptionally
beautiful and offers the quiet shelter
of Harbors to Navigators abundantly
providing the city with the necessities
of life and making it rich in all useful
things and on either side of it the two
continents are placed
Constantine built Constantinople
self-consciously as an imitation of Rome
and thus bestowed upon it all the sorts
of structures that one found in the
western Capital such as palaces temples
and arenas for Chariot racing
within the protective walls
Constantinople held probably over half a
million people
by contrast Rome in the year 500 had
only about thirty thousand and it
boasted a bustling urban life a Broad
Street the Messi LED through beautiful
city squares to the great Forum of
Constantine
the Heights on the edge of the peninsula
lay the vast Palace complex visitors had
to enter the palace through a huge
anti-chamber with roof and doors of
gilded bronze
behind its doorway the palace grounds
stretched down forested slopes to a wall
surrounding the Sea of marmara and the
Bosphorus
in subsequent centuries
the power and reach of the Byzantine
Empire waned
but safe behind its Great Walls the city
of Constantinople itself persisted
it played a key role as a staging point
for the Crusades and for centuries
served as a bulwark protecting Europe
from Eastern Invaders
then in one of the most ignominious
episodes of the Crusades the Christian
Army Of The Fourth Crusade duplicitously
turned against Constantinople and sacked
the city
fatally weakened by this betrayal as
well as by further declines in its
fortunes Constantinople was finally
captured by the ottoman Sultan Mehmet II
on May 29
1453 at last bringing the history of the
Eastern Roman Empire to an end
almost a thousand years after the fall
of Rome and the Western Empire
the ottoman Turks got their foothold in
Byzantine lands because of the plague
they found the depopulated portions of
Anatolia and the Balkans to be ripe for
almost bloodless conquest and settlement
in the realm of religion other parts of
the world saw instability due to a rise
of mysticism and a desire for people to
approach God directly
while the Turks proclaimed the sultan to
be God's representative they wisely
accepted Sufism an Islamic mysticism as
part of the religious experience in the
Turkish lands
sufis became organized into groups
called tarikas or orders each with its
own practice
within these orders aspiring sufis Place
themselves under the guidance of a
master
some people lived in lodges with other
members of their communities
some orders focused on the ecstatic
expression of religion that we see with
the whirling dervishes but others
offered more syncretic kinds of
experiences that helped blend
non-muslims into ottoman Society
one such influential order was called
the bhaktashi which began in the Balkans
they believed that official religious
practices represented simply an external
form of religion so they did not
emphasize the strict five pillars of
Islam instead they assimilated some
Christian beliefs like confession of
sins that made it easier for Christians
to live in harmony with their Muslim
overlords
in part this toleration of a certain
flexibility in religious expression
allowed the Ottoman Empire to serve as a
refuge for Christians and Jews who were
free to follow their own religion in
Turkish lands
during their religious repression of the
early modern period like the imposition
of the Spanish Inquisition to seek Out
secret Jews and Muslims many found
refuge in the lands of the Turks
and so in the 14th century they were
able to establish an ottoman State
rising from the ashes of plague and
intolerance that was causing so much
disruption everywhere else
all that remained as a barrier to
Turkish control was the great medieval
city of Constantinople
by 1355 the Ottomans had effectively
surrounded Constantinople whose Great
Walls had foiled invaders for almost a
thousand years
now the city had to face a new threat
that appeared in the 14th century
gunpowder
the Ottomans had been using gunpowder
weapons since the 1380s the Turks
employed a formidable military based on
an unusual Elite Force called the
janissaries
they were slaves who had been raised
from Boyhood and trained to fight for
the sultan
as the Turks took over the Balkans they
forced occupied peoples to pay a tribute
of boys
you would think that a slave Army
wouldn't be effective but these boys
converted to Islam and took pride in
their training and skills
in addition to swords they were trained
to fight with guns and small cannon
artillery and the sultan rewarded their
loyalty with wealth and prestige
surrounded by Turkish forces the city of
Byzantium was at risk things came to a
head in 1451 when a new Young Sultan
mehmed II decided to attack the city
now the Ottomans weren't the first to
attack Constantinople far from it
over the centuries as far back as the
7th Century literally dozens of attempts
were made to take Constantinople
the Ottomans were only the latest in a
succession of would-be conquerors
but it's easy to see why they were Keen
for this objective
at the time of this assault the ottoman
Capital was the city of ederne at the
edge of Europe and 140 miles west of
Constantinople
the Ottomans had amassed significant
European territories and all of Anatolia
that is the Peninsular territory that
comprises much of modern-day turkey
if they could turn back for a moment to
conquer Constantinople
they'd no longer have this source of
annoyance and trouble to their rear
its possession would allow them to push
even further into Europe
now another reason why the young Sultan
Mahmoud II wanted the city
was because since the start of the
Ottoman period in 1299
Constantinople had offered refuge for
Challengers to the ottoman leadership
this was a policy that continued under
the incumbent and last of the Byzantine
Emperor's Constantine XI
indeed for Generations Constantinople
was something of a safe haven for
disgruntled brothers half-brothers and
other male relatives of successive
ottoman rulers
anytime the Byzantine emperor wanted to
cause trouble he could set loose one of
these ottoman Pretenders and let them
launch military campaigns against
ottoman domains
a final undeniable reason why the
Ottomans so eagerly sought
Constantinople was because it was
renowned as a place of great wealth
letters from Muslim ottoman commanders a
test that while it was all well to talk
about this as a war against the
Christian Realm what interested the
troops most was getting rich Let's
consider the state of Constantinople and
the Byzantine empire in 1453
by this time the Roman Empire had
essentially been reduced to a few square
miles of land around Constantinople and
on the Peloponnesian peninsula in
southern Greece
now such a decline didn't occur
overnight it was a gradual process that
took hold over several centuries
indeed while the Christian Crusaders
previous attack on Constantinople and
surrounding lands had been disastrous
for the empire
turkic tribes also had been attacking
byzantium's Holdings in nearby Anatolia
or modern turkey since the 11th century
one of these tribes became known as the
Ottomans
the fact that Constantinople had
withstood so many invasions in the past
is an important point to bear in mind as
we move ahead with our story
Time and Again The Defenders success was
due to an impressive system of double
defensive walls and a moat which
together provided a three-fold defense
any attacker had to take on
for those unwilling to make a frontal
assault by land
they'd face equally formidable defenses
on the waterfront whether approaching
from the sea of marmara or the Golden
Horn
the two bodies of water alongside the
city
still walls moats and seaward defenses
were not absolute guarantors of security
sometimes you need allies too
and these were proving hard to come by
for the Christian byzantines
their obvious Ally when confronted by
invading Muslims would have been another
Christian Force namely Rome and her
allies
Rome after having been down at mouth for
some time the Western Empire remember
had fallen a thousand years earlier
was now enjoying an amazing Resurgence
that would bring us the Italian
Renaissance
unsurprisingly however
after the sack of Constantinople by a
Latin Crusader Army in 1204 relations
between the temporal powers and two
branches of Christianity had suffered
when a Byzantine emperor requested
assistance from Rome
a typical response was for Rome to bring
up the question of Primacy that is to
say to demand that the Orthodox Church
recognized the leadership of Rome which
the byzantines were obviously loathed to
do
during the lead-up to the ottoman
assault in 1453 Rome didn't refuse
appeals for help Point Blank
but what they did offer Constantine the
11th for the defense of Constantinople
was too little and as it would turn out
too late
we know how many troops Constantine the
11th had at his disposal because he
ordered a roll call
his army numbered
4773 Greeks plus 3 000 non-greek
foreigners including some Turkish troops
and even one Scotsman a mining engineer
named John Grant
by way of contrast the ottoman Sultan
had a much larger more fully functioning
Empire at this stage
not only did Mehmet II command a
professional standing army but he could
also demand the services of troops based
in Anatolia and Europe
these subjects of the sultan
including Serbian Christians and Turkish
Muslims had no choice but to answer his
Call to Arms
while we can't be certain estimates for
mehmed's Army suggest as many as 60 000
Ottomans against the fewer than 8 000
Byzantine Defenders
in addition to these fighting men
mehmed's Army was supported by thousands
of laborers Ordnance Specialists and
Mining Engineers all of whom played
important roles
now that we've seen the two sides ranged
against each other let's consider The
Siege itself
and the weapons and tactics used on both
sides
until this time
sieges usually favored Defenders
obviously it was essential for those
under attack to have access to clean
water and food
but in this respect Constantinople was
well served and for this reason
the big difference in size of the two
armies was by no means a guarantee of
Ottoman victory
safe behind City walls the Byzantine
Defenders were initially fairly
confident that they could see off the
attacking forces as the city had done
dozens of times before
however a technological Advance had
radically altered the balance of power
in a word canons
The Assault on Constantinople in 1453
wasn't the first time cannons were used
in battle that occurred more than a
century earlier
but improved technology allowed for the
casting of much larger armaments which
could fire larger objects over longer
distances
here the Ottomans had a distinct
advantage
although not even this was guaranteed
just a few months before the start of
the offensive
a man from Hungary named Urban who was
one of the master Canon makers of his
day had first offered his services to
the Byzantine emperor
but Constantine the 11th said he
couldn't afford Urban's asking price and
so the Hungarian turned instead to the
Ottomans
promising the sultan mehmed II that he
could build a cannon that would shake
the walls of Babylon
Urban was eagerly engaged
in January of 1453 Urban cast his
greatest gun it was enormous the barrel
was 26 feet long it could throw a stone
ball weighing more than a thousand
pounds which could sail more than a mile
Landing with great forests it was
cumbersome
60 to 100 oxen were needed to move the
giant gun 700 men were assigned to the
crew
by April the huge gun was placed in
front of the Turkish line aimed directly
at the Great Walls of Constantinople
on April 12th the bombardment began no
one had seen or heard such Firepower
before
on the downside this new weapon wasn't
without its fault
it wasn't very maneuverable nor was it
very accurate and finally it was so
large that it took three hours to reload
after every shot was fired
what that meant was that in any 24-hour
period the cannon could be fired only
eight times
it was said that the delay between shots
was usually long enough to allow the
Defenders to repair any damage done by
the previous burst before the next shot
was fired
whatever the truth of the matter it was
this cannon that made the difference and
eventually ensured victory for the
ottoman attackers
the Relentless pounding began to Break
Down The Walls and the deafening noise
wore down people's resolve finally on
May 29th the wall was breached the elite
janissaries swept through the wall
opened the gate and the city was taken
according to one eyewitness Constantine
himself threw off his purple Imperial
robe and charged sword in hand into the
ranks of his ottoman foes
the emperor's body was never found
once stripped of his Imperial robes
Constantine would have looked in death
just the same as one of his soldiers one
among the thousands who died in battle
by midday the Ottomans had broken any
serious resistance and Constantinople
was theirs
reaching the Aya Sofia which was packed
with civilians the Muslim Invaders broke
down the doors and divided the terrified
citizens into groups according to how
much ransom they might get
wealthy notables and their families were
among the lucky ones
in the rest of the city
Sultan mehmed II permitted his troops
three days of pillaging during which
time anything they could take away was
theirs for the keeping
such a system saw some Grow Rich
overnight as they filled sacks with gold
jewels and other portable plunder
when mehmed himself entered
Constantinople however the scale of the
destruction and Slaughter is said to
have horrified him
according to one eyewitness blood flowed
like rain water in the gutters after a
sudden storm
and the bodies of Turks and Christians
floated like melons along a canal
mehmed is supposed to have broken down
in tears at the site
totally destroyed mehmed planned to use
it as his new capital and from then on
he is known as mehmed the Conqueror
he called the city Istanbul by which it
is known today
the name was not formally changed from
Constantinople until 1930.
the great palace that overlooked the sea
became the new Palace for the sultan
the great church of Haya Sophia that was
the pride of Eastern Christendom was
hastily converted to a mosque the Fresco
images were covered and four minarets
were built to call the faithful to
prayer
The Sultans celebrated the victory in
the great church
we assume the Gunner Urban was well paid
for his services
news of the fall of Constantinople
reached Italy in about a month
Christendom was stunned a cardinal wrote
The Glory of the East The Refuge of all
good things has been captured
the fall of Constantinople in 1453 the
same year as the end of the Hundred
Years War marks the end of the Middle
Ages
the world was changed the Turks spread
throughout the Balkans the Middle East
and North Africa they even laid Siege to
Vienna deep into Western territory
their impact on the Balkan States
extends well into the modern era
the new Muslim conquerors added to the
diversity of the Region's population
that existed on the borders of cultural
and religious differences
for examples the serbs were Eastern
Orthodox the croats Catholics and those
in Kosovo were largely Muslims
this mixture of peoples marks the modern
world in which the idea of a country
unified by religion belongs in the past
Turks recognized and accepted this
diversity but wars in the Modern Age
changed the balance
the conquest of Constantinople also
shaped Russia's history
the Duke of Moscow Ivan III had married
a niece of the Byzantine emperor when
the Byzantine empire fell Ivan
proclaimed Moscow to be the Third Rome
successor of the Roman Empire that fell
at the beginning of the Middle Ages and
the Byzantine Empire that fell at the
end of the Middle Ages Ivan took the
title Caesar or Czar in recognition of
his claim of legitimacy
the rule of the tsars of Russia marks
the beginning of the early modern age in
Russia and these dynasties ruled until
the 20th century
[Music]
thanks for watching if you'd like to
learn more about the topics in this
episode the full list of series that
these clips came from is in the
description below you can watch them all
now on wandria